okay thanks Nathan so I'm going to talk
about complexity of quantum impurity
problems this is joint work with Sergey
bravi and let me first tell you what the
topic of the talk is and try to convince
you that it's interesting so a quantum
impurity model is a system of Fermi
modes consisting of a non interacting
bath so free for me on bath coupled to
potentially strongly interacting
impurity but the impurity is small so
just to be a little bit more precise
although will be even more precise later
we're just talking about hamiltonians
which describe n firming modes and
there's a term which is quadratic and
their creation annihilation operators
that's the free for me on part and
there's a term which acts non-trivial II
only on a constant number of modes and
that term can have interactions okay so
why should we care well these models
have a long history and physics going
back to the 1930s when it was discovered
that metals like gold when they have
impurities the resistance can go down as
you lower temperature but then it can go
back up again and that was a surprise
and the theoretical understanding of
this what was later called the condo
effect didn't come until 30 or 40 years
later and the the understanding came
from defining these quantum impurity
models and understanding that electrons
in these metals can become localized in
impurities and then other electrons can
scatter off of them which caused the
resistance to go up so that's some
context from physics but more a more
contemporary context would be a
numerical method called dynamical mean
field theory this is a classical
numerical technique whereby one aims to
simulate a quantum many-body system on a
lattice by modeling it as a quantum
impurity
so the goal in dynamical mean field
theory is to select a quantum impurity
model which mimics the physics of your
lattice model that you care about so
this figure which I didn't draw but it's
supposed to indicate on the left some
lattice model and on the right an
impurity model which mimics its physics
and the arrows are supposed to indicate
that in dynamical mean field theory
there's an iterative procedure to choose
the parameters of the impurity model
that best mimic the physics of the
lattice model and a time-consuming step
in this classical numerical method the
mft is solving for properties of the
impurity model which has to be done
repeatedly in this iterative process now
in quantum computing it was recently
suggested by Bella Bauer and the
Microsoft group that maybe one could
speed up this dynamical mean field
theory simulation using a quantum
computer now this figure I don't know
it's probably too small for you to see
but maybe I'll just draw your attention
to the red text on the right of the
figure this is a figure from this
Microsoft paper and it says solve
impurity problem on quantum computer so
that's the part of the algorithm which
is quantum and the rest of the algorithm
is classical and their proposal well
what they propose that you should first
prepare the ground state of a quantum
impurity model and they propose using
quantum adiabatic evolution to do this
although in the worst case there's not a
upper bound on the runtime of that
procedure and then once they have the
ground state then they can compute this
greens function which is needed for
dynamical mean field theory by using
Hamiltonian simulation which can be done
efficiently on a quantum computer ok so
all this got us thinking you know what
can we prove about quantum impurity
models in the general case and we would
like to address this question from the
perspective of Hamiltonian complexity so
we'll talk about approximating ground
energy or computing low energy states so
let me now talk about where we stand so
on the left hand side I have a column
for free from yawns that's where you
have n non-interacting from yawns and on
the right hand side I have a column for
like fully interacting models and then
in the middle we have this
quantum of purity model which somehow
interpolates between the two where we
have a constant size impurity and and
the rest of the modes are not
interacting and so we can ask you know
can we get concise descriptions of
ground states or low energy states and
can we compute the ground energy
efficiently for example so for free from
yawns it's well known that just by
linear algebra by diagonalizing matrices
one can compute the the ground energy in
polynomial time and the ground state is
also a something called a fermionic
Gaussian state which we'll talk about in
a moment and is specified by order N
squared complex numbers so this is
straightforward in the case of fully
interacting models even on a 2d lattice
we know that it's qma hard to compute
the ground energy and so it's also
unlikely that there's an efficient
description classical description of the
ground state and so what I'm going to
tell you about in this talk is that we
can in fact get concise descriptions of
the ground state of these impurity
models and we can efficiently compute
the ground energy although I've colored
these check marks in orange because the
results are not as strong as the green
check marks in the first column and so
I'm going to give more details about
that as we go on okay so that's going to
be the rest of the talk and here's
here's the plan so first I'm going to
talk about fermionic Hilbert space and
fermionic Gaussian states and then I'm
going to talk about our results on the
structure of ground states of these
models and then I'll talk about our
algorithms okay starting with setup so
the fermionic hilbert space can people
hear me at the back is it yeah ok so the
fermionic hilbert space of n fermionic
modes is spanned by foxes states it's a
2 to the N dimensional space and so you
can label the basis vectors by bit
strings of length n which just you know
can be obtained from some reference
state the vacuum state by applying for
meiotic creation operators in this talk
it's going to be convenient to work with
instead of the standard fermionic and
creation creation and annihilation
operators we're going to work with my
arana operators which are just obtained
from this linear transformation
from the creation and I elation
operators and these these Mariners have
the nice property that they're her
mission and the anti commute for
different indices and square to the
identity now you might say well I don't
like thinking about from Yannick Hilbert
space I like cubits and well all of this
is just can be thought of as a system of
n qubits where this basis this fog basis
is just the computational basis and
these marana operators can be just
written as the following subset of n
cubed pally operators so there's nothing
mysterious about the silver space now
let me define what it means to be a
Gaussian unitary so a unitary is
Gaussian if it under conjugation Maps
every marana operator to a linear
superposition of my illness and here
these coefficients are JK are real
because the meijer Ana's are hermitian
but just because u is unitary one can
also deduce that they form this are
forms an orthogonal matrix okay a
fermionic Gaussian state is a state
obtained from the vacuum state that all
0 state by applying a Gaussian unitary
so these are just definitions this is a
so here's a couple of useful facts about
Gaussian Unitarian states so first of
all ghosts and unitary is diagonalized
free fer me on hamiltonians we're going
to see an example of that in a moment
the second fact is that there's an
analogy between gaussian states and
stabilizer states they're somehow a
fermionic analog of stabilizer states
and in particular we can represent them
efficiently I said before a Gaussian
state requires order N squared complex
numbers to represent I'm not really
going to state what that representation
is but it's not complicated and we can
also manipulate them efficiently so for
example we can compute inner products
between Gaussian states in polynomial
time we can also compute expectation
value of my run operators and so on ok
so now let me define this class of
quantum impurity model Hamiltonians
that we consider so again it's a sum of
two terms a bath preferring on bath and
an impurity term the bath Hamiltonian is
a completely general free for me on
Hamiltonian which when written in terms
of my renault operators is a quadratic
expression the coefficients hij just
because this has to be a hermitian
matrix that has to be a real
anti-symmetric matrix and now I'm saying
that without loss of generality I want
to take the norm of that hij matrix to
be one or at most one and this is going
to be without loss of generality because
i'm not going to restrict the norm of
the second term in the hamiltonian so i
can always make this norm won by just
rescaling the whole hamiltonian okay the
impurity hamiltonian well we said it has
to only act on a constant number m of
the modes of my honest but otherwise
it's going to be unrestricted now you
might say well what about this
restriction where I mean so here look
I've written the expression and you can
see that it it is a sum of all the
monomials in these marana operators 1
through m but there is this restriction
that the this bit string X that appears
in the slum has to be even or that it's
Hamming weight has to be even and that
corresponds to the restriction that the
Hamiltonian conserves the parody of the
firm young number which is a physical
symmetry that always satisfied so it's
not really restricted at all and these
coefficients G sub X are just arbitrary
there's no bounds on their magnitude for
example ok now I mentioned a moment ago
that free fermion Hamiltonians are
diagonalized by Gaussian unitary so now
let me just describe what that means
here for the bath Hamiltonian so that
means that we can choose new fermi mode
fermi creation and annihilation
operators bj bj dagger such that the
hamiltonian has the form constant times
the identity plus this sum of single
particle excitation energies epsilon J
times bj dagger bj so here BJ dagger bj
counts the number of fermions in this
new Fermi mode we've defined and the
epsilon JS r can be thought of
the single-particle excitation energies
and these new firming modes the bjs
those are called the canonical modes and
they're obtained from the original Fermi
modes by a Gaussian unitary
transformation and the single particle
excitation energies are always in the
unit interval because of this choice of
the norm of this little H matrix and
just one more definition before the fun
stuff that we're it's going to be
convenient to define the smallest non 0
epsilon J to be the spectral gap of the
bath Hamiltonian so that's pretty much
the entire setup and now we get to have
fun oh one more thing this constant term
e naught times the identity is just
inconvenient to drag that around so
we're just going to subtract it off
because it's a constant and we're going
to not write it in the expressions
coming up okay so now let's talk about
the structure of the ground state of
these models so let's define a matrix
for a given let's say sigh as a ground
state of an impurity model and remember
we're writing beat these be operators of
the canonical modes of the bath okay and
we're going to define an n-by-n matrix
which is just well it's written right
here we're calling it seeds we're going
to call it the ground state covariance
matrix and a numerical observation if
you take some examples on your on MATLAB
is that the eigen values of this matrix
decay rapidly so let me show you an
example here's an example of a random
instance of an impurity model with 11
Fermi modes and an impurity of size M
equals 4 and on the y-axis it's a
semi-log plot so the y-axis is log and
you can see that the jet eigen value
decreases very rapidly with J the J
largest eigen value so this is just
numerical observation and then you can
ask you know how general is this and why
should we care so let me first address
the generality and this is our main
technical result which is that in fact
it's very general so there for any
impurity model there
always exist to ground state such that
if you look at the eigenvalues of the
ground state covariance matrix they
decay exponentially and moreover the
exponential decay is controlled only by
the size of the impurity and the bath
spectral gap and in particular it has no
dependence on n the total number of
Fermi moans okay I'm not going to say
very much about the proof of this and so
I'm not really going to do it justice
because as I said it's our main
technical result and the proof is
somewhat involved but I will just
mention the two steps of the proof at a
high level so the first one the first
step is that we use a variational
characterization of ground states to
show that this matrix see the ground
state covariance matrix for any ground
state satisfies a set of matrix
inequalities which I've written here so
these in qualities involve see but they
also involve a projector lambda as well
as another matrix e and I've written in
red the two the two inequalities which
are somehow the most interesting the
rest of the register of defining lambda
and E and then we show that any matrix e
satisfying this set of inequalities has
the claimed exponential decay and this
part uses a theory of rational
approximation and in particular
something called zealot revs rational
approximation to the square root
function which is very economical with
respect to the degree of the
approximation or the degree of the
rational functions which achieve a given
approximation but if you're interested I
suggest having a look at our paper and
right now I would like to focus on the
consequences of this for the questions
that we asked at the beginning of the
top so first of all let me mention that
the theorem holds for all impurity
models and it has no dependence on the
actual form of the impurity except for
its size oh we can prove a slightly
stronger version of the theorem if all
the excitation energies are strictly
positive so in particular in the theorem
it says there exists a ground state but
in this case one would get for all
ground states and okay so now let me
address the question why should we care
I mean so we talked about why it you
know this
this this numerical observation actually
turned out to be quite general but now
why should we care well we should care
because it actually implies quite
straightforwardly that a ground state
has a concise classical representation
so let's see how that goes so we're
going to talk about approximations of
the following form imagine on the left
hand side we've divided up the N fermi
modes into K & N minus K and we're
setting n minus K in the vacuum state or
all zeros and the the first k we're
going to just choose to be some state it
doesn't have to be a Gaussian state it
could just be any state of K modes and
we're going to imagine plugging in that
n mode state into a Gaussian unitary and
our goal is to get a good approximation
to the ground state let's say you know
Delta with respect to the you know if
you just take the difference of the two
states and take the norm of that it
should be within Delta and the quest
obviously we can make this work if k is
equal to n because then we just set the
unitary to be the identity and and Phi
could be the ground state and we're done
but obviously we want this to work with
small K and why do we want it to work
with small K well on the left hand side
we have a superposition of two to the K
basis vectors each of which is a
Gaussian state and when you apply a
Gaussian unitary that map's Gaussian
states to Gaussian states so on the
right hand side our approximation would
be a superposition of two to the K
Gaussian States so we would really like
to make this work with small K and in
fact a corollary of this exponential
decay theorem is that one can take k to
be given by the following expression
which is kind of kind of well it's kind
of ugly but one thing to notice is that
it doesn't depend on n it depends only
on the size of the impurity m the
spectral gap of the bath Omega and the
desired precision Delta so right so this
this Gaussian rank this you know the
output is a superposition of Chi equals
2 to the K Gaussian States and that has
no explicit dependence on n although it
may depend on n through the spectral gap
of the bath
moreover it says that all excitation zin
this approximation can be localized on
2k modes by applying this Gaussian unit
air and let me just as a side note
mention that we can get a slightly
better bound if we don't require that
ladder property so if we didn't have
this log log term Chi would be
polynomial in the inverse spectral gap
of the bath and we can I in fact prove
that bound with a slightly different
form of the approximation okay so let me
just show you how this proof goes
because it it basically is a direct
consequence of this exponential decay
theorem that you just saw so here's how
it goes the exponential decay theorem
says that almost all the eigenvalues of
this ground state covariance matrix are
really tiny okay so now let's focus on
one eigenvector that has a small
eigenvalue so suppose V is this
eigenvector with the tiny eigenvalue
well then we can define a new firming
mode operator which I've written as
capital B which is just the sum of the
canonical modes waited by the entries of
this eigen vector V and a direct
consequence of the fact that V is an
eigenvector of C with small eigenvalue
is that sigh you know sandwiching B
dagger B is almost zero it's very small
and so what does this say it says that
for each tiny eigen value of C we have a
new fermi mode which is unoccupied with
high probability and so what do we do we
choose this you which transforms to this
new set of Fermi modes and that allows
us to go from the ground state to a
state where almost all the framing modes
are unoccupied sorry did I say you I
mean u dagger is the thing that goes
from the ground state to the thing where
most of the firming modes are unoccupied
so that's almost the whole proof I mean
obviously there's details but it's not
much more than that so now we get our
first answer to this question that we
asked which is that a ground state is
approximated to any constant precision
by a superposition of a small number of
Gaussian states and in fact we can take
that small number to be just polynomial
in the inverse spectral gap of the bath
for a constant impurity size but we
don't get an algorithm and we don't get
an algorithm because if you actually try
to
look at the proof that we just went
through or the sketch of the proof to
construct this approximation you need to
know the ground state covariance matrix
but then if you don't know the ground
state how do you get the ground state
covariance matrix so we don't have an
algorithm yet but but that's the next
thing I'm going to talk about I mean yet
at this point in the talk but ok so we
do have an algorithm and here is what it
does it's a classical algorithm and it
computes the ground energy of a quantum
impurity model to a given error epsilon
and it has the following runtime now the
thing to note about this runtime is that
first of all it scales polynomially in
the system size and the total number of
Fermi modes it has so M remember is
constant I just put it in here because
you know you might be interested in how
it scales with the impurity size but M
here is constant so the only other
interesting thing in this expression is
the scaling with the inverse error which
is quazy polynomial it's not polynomial
if that three the log cubed was a log
then it would be polynomial in the
universe error but it's not it's Kwazii
polynomial and we would you know we'd
like to improve it but that's what we
got the scaling with them actually is
close to optimal or at least close to
the best you could imagine getting
because when m is equal to n you know
you're just solving some general
interacting fermi system and we expect
that to take exponential time maybe you
could get rid of the log dependence on a
pub finally the algorithm produces a
classical description of a state with
low energy in particular with energy at
most epsilon and the state is also a
superposition of a small number of
Gaussian states in fact the number of
Gaussian states in the superposition is
just given by this exponential factor
that also appears in the runtime ok so
let's see how much time do I have about
10 minutes yeah ok great so I'm going to
run through sort of how the algorithm
works but in order to be able to do that
in the time that's lauded i'm just going
to state two facts and then we're going
to use those facts to sort of describe
the algorithm so the first fact is I'm
going to call the decoupling trick so
you just have to remember the names of
these tricks and sort of
what they do so the first thing is this
decoupling trick which says that if the
bath Hamiltonian has a lot of degeneracy
in the single-particle spectrum then
things simplify greatly that's the trick
in particular if there are D distinct
single particle energies then we can
apply a Gaussian unitary transformation
which decouples all except d times m
modes from the impurity so in the
situation where there's few distinct
single particle energies you can reduce
the problem to one in which there's few
modes left after this decoupling
transformation okay so that's the first
thing the second thing oh this thing is
easy to prove its it's just linear
algebra it doesn't use any of the facts
I mentioned before the second thing is
what I'm going to call the few
excitation subspace so this actually is
a consequence of this exponential decay
theorem it's not not easy to prove but
what it says is that if we're interested
in approximating the ground energy with
precision epsilon we can restrict our
attention to a subspace with few
excitation in particular a number which
scales in the way written on the slide
you'll notice that the number of
excitations doesn't depend on n so here
for four people that aren't physicist
the number of excitations is you know
after transforming to this new set of
modes it's the number of ones in the in
a basis vector or the number of particle
okay okay so now i can describe the
algorithm and hopefully it'll be i mean
it's sort of at a high level but
hopefully it won't be too onerous so the
first thing is very simple we just
diagonalize the the bath hamiltonian and
we already said that you can do that
with linear algebra in in order n cubed
time so just compute all the single
protocol energies and the canonical
modes okay the second step is a
discretization of the single particle
spectrum so we're going to take the bath
Hamiltonian and we're going to
discretize all the single particle
energies to a uniform grid with some
spacing Delta okay and then we're going
to construct a new impurity problem
where we take that discretized bath
Hamiltonian and add the old you know the
old impurity term to it now I haven't
said what Delta is going to be and that
sort of the interesting question we want
the error introduced
just in the ground energy to be order
epsilon so the question is how fine
should we choose this grid and there's
sort of obvious things that you can do
that will guarantee that the grid
spacing is fine enough to give you this
error but we're not going to do those
obvious things we're going to do
something which is more interesting and
I claim that it actually suffices to
choose this Delta to be well to scale in
the following way with epsilon and M and
in particular you don't have to have
Delta depend on n at all it doesn't
depend on the total number of modes it
only depends on the impurity size in the
air and what you might say well that
seems to course because it doesn't
depend on n and moreover you can sort of
easily see that the norm of the new
impurity problem you know the
Hamiltonian minus the Hamiltonian for
the old impurity problem that can be
really large like it could be linear in
n so it seems like it's not a good idea
to take the grid to be this course but
actually we're not interested in like
the norm of this difference within the
whole Hilbert space we're only
interested in this few excitation
subspace where we know there's a low
energy state and so one can show that
the norm of the difference restricted to
that to that subspace has the norm that
norm is order epsilon which is what we
want so that's sort of the first trick
but now now we've discretized this
really coarse grid and we had n single
particle energies and now we have a
number of energies which is independent
of n so we've introduced a lot of
degeneracy in the bath Hamiltonian so
now what are we going to do we're going
to use the decoupling trick which is a
good thing to do when you have
degeneracy in the single particle
spectrum and so then well because well
after we use this trick the number of
modes that are left coupled to the
impurity is at most M times the number
of distinct single particle energies
which is given by this expression and
you'll notice it doesn't depend on n but
this decoupling unitary commutes with
the number operator for the canonical
modes so we can now further
strict to the few excitation subspace so
now the last step of the algorithm is
just to compute the smallest eigen value
of the Hamiltonian in the subspace with
that many modes and that many at most
that many expectations and that subspace
has a small dimension and so there's a
lit a line I'm sweeping under the rug
like I mean well not really I mean to
compute to compute the small Fagin value
have to compute all the entries and
computing each entry actually takes
order n cube time because you have to
manipulate these basis vectors which in
our case can be taken to be coasting
states but this is basically essentially
how it goes ok ok so now we get we get
to fill out this second row of the table
that we have a classical algorithm with
runtime polynomial in n kwasi polynomial
in the air and we also get to put in
another row in this for another entry in
this first row which is that if you're
interested in a low energy state we can
achieve a Gaussian rank that only
depends on em and the the upper bound on
the air or on the energy ok so let me
now conclude with a few extensions that
we have in our paper and some open
questions so obviously a natural open
question is you know can we improve this
quazy polynomial scaling with the air
and another way to rephrase that or
slightly slight variant of that question
is what is the complexity of
approximating the ground energy with
inverse polynomial error in n and you
know in that error regime our algorithm
doesn't do very well epsilon is inverse
polynomial in n but we we can prove
nevertheless proven upper bound on the
complexity of that problem we show that
it's contained in this complexity class
QC MA which is like NP with a classical
witness and quantum verifier ok but it
would be interesting for example to get
an algorithm in that regime I mean are
going to fish an algorithm which we
don't have you might ask well is this
algorithm practical and in our paper we
have a section devoted to developing a
practical version of our
which differs in some important places
from the algorithm for which we prove
bounds but the practical version is
based on using the set of low rank
Gaussian states or superpositions of
small number of Gaussian States as a
variational on sets and on some simple
example we show that it achieves good
good error okay you might also ask about
other questions related to simulating
these quantum impurity models for
example you might ask about time
evolution like how hard is it to
simulate the time evolution of these
impurity models because for example
that's something that is done in this
Microsoft algorithm but an interesting
thing is that if you look there's a
paper by Daniel Bodin andrew child's
which is not doesn't mention impurity
problems but if you I mean it's it's
it's sort of straightforwardly implies
that time evolution sure during your
time evolution with a time-dependent
Hamiltonian which describes an impurity
model can't be efficiently simulated on
a classical computer unless bv p equals
b QP so in other words time-dependent
impurity model hamiltonians can do
universal quantum computation which is
sort of interesting it would be
interesting though if that could be
extended to time independent Schrodinger
time evolution finally I think it's
interesting to ask whether or not there
are further applications of these low
rank Gaussian states and also whether or
not there's further more to be said
about the analogue between Gaussian and
stabilizer states and let me mention
that we we do in our paper have some new
technical tools along these lines we
have for example in an appendix
condition under which an ensemble of
Gaussian States forms an analog of a to
design it's not quite a to design but
it's good enough in in some some cases
okay so I'll end there thank
alright excellent talk David questions
daveed no um so I was wondering coming
back to your motivation on the mft does
your result imply that there's like a
maximum size of a bath beyond which it
you don't gain anything for DNA dmft
like for a given em there's an end
beyond which oh because they would lead
to the same dis critize yeah I'm not
sure about that that's a good question I
don't know if the top of my head a
further questions
so in physics people often study other
kinds of impurity models for a cubit is
coupled to a bath of oscillators and
actually condensed matter physicists
often use tools to convert those
backwards and forwards to sort of Fermi
ones more similar to what you're talking
about I'm just wondering if you've
thought about if it has anything to say
about these sorts of techniques and
results everything to say or could
conceivably be applied to think about
that a sort of cute couple two baths
kind of impurity models I guess the
short answer is that I haven't thought
about it but it's a good question any
further questions all right if not let's
take our speaker
[Applause]